hey guys Ryan right here I have been
requested up the wazoo I'm telling you
my [ __ ] is itching from the amount of
requests that I've got of this ass
Batman Arkham Knight AC II or ace I'm
pretty sure tastes like Ace Ventura pet
detective
all righty then we're gonna watch the
batman trailer today chemicals trailer
part 1 let's get this show on the road
[Music]
whoever this guy is he's a symbol than
for me there's a cruel base chemicals
worker and select on-site they'll be
able to help us track down scarecrow and
locate his bomb
[Music]
[Music]
Jesus writes
hi
you're safe now they've been running the
plant for hours they've brought in
trucks with soldiers shipments of
hazardous materials they knew exactly
what they were doing where do I find
scarecrow all I know is he's moving
ahead with his plan he's got a whole
frickin army backing him up
there's food that I wasted sound
familiar but first I'm getting you out
of here
great work I knew you wouldn't let us
down no I get just going back to the
other
they say so much fun
logic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was pretty sweet
I do heavily enjoy those Batman games I
got Batman Arkham origins on my iPhone
even and that I play that game all the
time that's how invested I am in this
franchise but I play the iPhone version
all the time
that's where the real respecting cred is
act I love the use of the Batmobile like
the Batmobile use is just [ __ ] it
makes it just so much more fun like you
can fly places and share those grappling
crafts we can like pull himself up
places and if he doesn't want to run
around or fly he just cops in this
[ __ ] battle tank that he's got going
on you could use all these different
mechanics that just keep the gameplay
alive and keep it going throughout what
sucks is when a game you have to go
through their boring parts of the game
and I feel like that will be more easily
avoided in this one yeah cuz you know i
remember playing arkham asylum and just
being like there's so much of this
walking but if a Batmobile can just sort
of like take care of that problem for me
that'd be pretty [ __ ] awesome yeah
i've been psyched for this game ever
since the first trailer came out and i'm
really interested in seeing scarecrow as
the villain because i actually
a long time ago read the scarecrow they
had this anthology of a bunch of
different scarecrow origin tales and
even featured the original and I've
always thought scarecrow would be a
really fantastic villain if he really
had the chance to shine and be fully
fleshed out like I know he was in Batman
Begins but there's so much insane cool
backstory to this guy such a deep
methodical psychology about this dude
that's is so [ __ ] awesome it is scary
and intimidating I'm looking forward to
seeing scarecrow really like take the
lead as the villain in this anyway guys
thanks for telling that trailer was out
seriously I've waited too long to watch
it if you're do half of long if you're
too long to wait if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects they did that bad boys do the
Batman voice
dalek Xander wit ham hey can you give me
a shoutout
Alexander wit ham dude I like the name
and Alexander it sounds like the D is
silent so your name would be Alexander
just like Django where the D is silent
and it big ache sometimes we were just
like do you like the size of my ich the
D is silent that's the joke
there you go delis and ER you get a
special joke how fortunate are you
Careca carousel whatever I'm gonna get
your name wrong jr. ragout hey Ryan I
subscribed a couple of months ago and I
love your channel keep it up dude give
me a shout-out winky face oh you mean
the winky face that means he wants the
ick dude I don't know if we can do this
hey it would have to be Augie style but
even still that's gross
I just wanted to say all yeast I am
referencing doggies thank you it's
lonely in here on a Sunday night
Morello Garrard oh hey Ryan what's up
can you give me a shout-out to Moro
supremo I love your channel and your
stupid jokes
okay another things please react to this
video no I'm not going to do that after
you call me stupid you want to shout out
to Moro supremo but you're gonna call me
stupid dude Moro supremo you know why
they call you that my dear [ __ ] photo
Varela Gerardo you've crossed the line
you fourteen-year-old boy so young Jesus
Christ never mind never mind I will be
nice to you you have um a lot of friends
though on your Facebook page good for
you I hope they're all real friends
they're all woman you're probably the
friendzone type you look like you've
been friendzone my friend
but trust me after ten years you might
be able to break down friends oniy there
right baby's gonna get a hell yeah hell
yeah